we averted another right-wing
insurrection oh gosh i'm so relieved
today march 5th yesterday was march 4th
when
i was assured by the mainstream media
that right-wing insurrectionist
trump supporting insurrectionists we're
going to launch a coup d'etat
you see that's the reason that the left
and the mainstream media
gave for extending the national guard in
d.c
that was the reason they gave for why
washington dc still looks like
baghdad like some occupied city but the
coup
it never came but they they still
extended the national guard in dc
huh so glad we haven't had an
insurrection
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from john doe who says
as a person of neanderthal ancestry i am
offended
by joe biden's comments he needs to be
held accountable
this is a very insightful
strategy for identity politics because i
read somewhere who knows i don't really
trust
most studies that come out that are
reported in the mainstream media
but there was one that says that uh
people who derive from places
other than africa the people who derive
from the near east from europe
from asia are uh in part in very small
part
neanderthal they found neanderthal dna
there so you can claim this you can say
i'm a member
even even if you say i have white
privilege i am a member of one of the
most oppressed groups
in history namely the neanderthals
one great way for you not to suffer the
same fate as some of our forebears
for you not to go extinct and for your
money not to go extinct is to check out
rockauto rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
one because you're gonna get the best
prices two they're a great business
and you know they're very reliable three
they're fair
to both pros and do-it-yourselfers they
get the same prices for both but four
this one is very important to me they
won't humiliate you
like happens when you go to the
brick-and-mortar store when you go in
and you start getting peppered with all
these questions hey
what kind of honda do you have and is it
this and is it that and is it the zt2
and is it you say i don't i don't know
what kind of honda i have
and it goes in the back they don't have
the car part they go online
probably to rockauto.com order the part
charge you twice as much the whole
experience
is humiliating save yourself that
degradation that indignity
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car
or truck once you find those absolute
perfect parts very easy you check out
their website is so simple to navigate
even i can do it then make sure you
don't forget this write knowles
k-w-l-e-s
and there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
go check them out fabulous fabulous
business
i i've been told that we avoided an
insurrection
which is why we have national guardsmen
stationed all around dc and we have
barbed wire and giant fences all around
our federal buildings because we avoided
an insurrection
now i'm no expert on coup d'etats but
it would seem to me that the the
uh world in which we have troops
stationed all around the capitol
and where we have giant buildings and
and uh giant gates and lots of barbed
wire
to my mind that that more closely
resembles a coup d'etat
than than ordinary functions of
government but this is what we were told
we were told this by the mainstream
media they're going to deny it now
they're going to say no we never said
anything about march 4th
they did cnn this is the date qnon
followers are looking forward to
forbes how donald trump's dc hotel feeds
q anon's march 4th conspiracy
cnn these trump supporters are convinced
he'll be president again on march 4th
washington post why march 4th matters to
cue anon extremists leading to fears of
another attack
abc house to rap early amid threat of
violence connected to q anon about march
4th
usa today police bolster security at u.s
capital as q anon claims
trump will become president march 4th
bbc we're talking now across the pond
why are q on believers obsessed with
march 4th and then finally the
washington post
at the capitol a march 4 threat by trump
q anon supporters
proves a mirage i spend a lot of time
in the right-wing media i'm sure that
many of you do as well
i never heard anything about march 4th
i saw a lot of commentary that was
asking why the national guard is still
stationed all around dc
but i didn't say anything about march
4th the only place i saw anything
hyping some kind of riot on march 4th
was in the mainstream media then it
didn't happen
and they take the fact that it didn't
happen as a good reason
why we need to now extend the national
guard in washington d.c
you understand we were told that we had
an insurrection on january 6
because there was not enough security in
washington dc
now we're being told that we didn't have
an insurrection on march 4th
because there was too much security in
washington d.c okay fair enough
and that's why we need to extend the
security in washington d.c
there's no end to this they're just
taking more and more power
they're very good at this joe biden
recognizes that nancy pelosi
is pushing now a an
a lethal threat to our political order
through the house of representatives joe
biden
while video chatting with nancy pelosi
he said
honey i admire the devil out of you
nancy
i love you there's no one i'd rather
work with than you we've been friends a
long time
and your whole family your daughters and
it has just been
a great relationship and uh you just
have
a special way about you nancy and you're
also uh
very very which is important you're kind
but you're tough
and you know what's right and you stick
by it and uh i admire the devil out of
you
biden's usually not great with his word
choice this one i think absolutely
spot on i admire the devil out of you
nancy pelosi i don't i can't say i
recognize a ton of divinity
in you but i certainly recognize the
devil and
oh gosh nancy i admire the devil out of
you i just love
practicing our dark arts together and
worshiping the lord of the underworld
yeah i just
love the devil out of you nancy is
pushing something called the
for the people act hr1
a breitbart had a good rundown on this
yesterday
this is i'm not going to say it's the
most radical legislation that probably
goes to the equality act which the house
just passed as well
this is is the crookedest legislation
i've seen go through
the house of representatives ever in my
lifetime hr1
is a an essential threat to our
constitutional order to our election
systems
hr1 gives congress control over
congressional elections says that
congress has broad authority
to regulate the time place and manner of
congressional elections
what could go wrong giving congressmen
the ability
to regulate their own elections what
could possibly go wrong not a power grab
at all right
uh hr one effectively outlaws voter id
the most basic ballot security measure
it effectively outlaws that says it's
burdensome
it limits legal challenges to its own
law
only dc courts can hear challenges to
hr1 which affects
our election systems all over the
country according to
to the law hr1 mandates automatic
and online voter registration so states
no longer have the right to
organize their own kind of voter
registration plans people will
automatically be registered and then
they've got to come off the rolls
however however if states try to take
ineligible voters off the voter rolls
that will also be much more difficult if
not impossible because of
hr1 hr1 protects illegal aliens who have
been automatically registered to vote
mandates same-day voter registration
mandates voter registration of 16 year
olds who are not allowed to vote yet but
they need to be registered to vote
it makes it i kid you not a federal
crime
to spread fake news about the elections
so
to give you just an example of this
there's an old joke you say
hey are you a republican make sure you
vote on tuesday oh you're a democrat
make sure you vote on thursday right
this is an old joke both parties have
said it for a long time
so in 2016 i posted a meme to this
effect you know democrats don't forget
to vote tomorrow
but republicans vote today i was
suspended from
facebook for a day or something like
that twitter maybe too i don't really
remember
according to hr1 i could face legal
consequences
for that that would become a federal
crime
uh mandatory early voting so it destroys
the idea of election day becomes
election season which is obviously much
more vulnerable to fraud
mandates vote by mail without photo id
which is according to some states
unconstitutional
this would make it a requirement
mandatory legal ballot harvesting so
that democrat operatives can go pick up
a bunch of ballots from
from people may be filled out by the
voters themselves maybe not
mandatory campus vote coordinator so it
puts a burden on colleges
to hire people to harvest votes
why are they going to harvest the votes
because the college is overwhelmingly
going to vote for democrats
and it establishes a commission to study
making washington d.c
a state washington dc exists
specifically
not to be a state the argument for dc is
that no state should control the seat of
federal power that's why they took some
some of maryland some of virginia and
they make it washington d.c now they
want to turn this into a state why it
gives democrats much more power
gives democrats two more votes in the
senate gives democrats another
congressman gives democrats an advantage
in presidential voting it's not just the
government seizing this kind of power
youtube is of course taking more and
more power not just from those of us who
say things that youtube doesn't like
on our channels not just those of us in
the media
or who are working in politics but are
not elected
they're now censoring trump they
obviously censored trump's youtube
channel
trump then gave a speech at cpac over
the weekend
youtube has censored that speech and has
suspended the channel that posted that
speech
the video was approaching 4 million
views can't have that
can't have that because some oligarchs
in silicon valley
are now going to control our political
discourse
and even if someone was a duly elected
president they're not permitted to speak
because google now gets veto power
beyond that
moving over to ebay beyond people
elected president now to the most
frivolous example dr
seuss is being banned from ebay we know
that dr
seuss publisher is no longer going to
publish the racist
dr seuss books dr seuss and part being
canceled
so because they're not being published
anymore the only place you're gonna be
able to get them is on
auction sites second hand ebay quote
is currently sweeping our marketplace to
remove these items
according to the wall street journal an
ebay spokesman said that it would take
time to review seller listings and
monitor
newly published listings dr seuss too
hot to read
this company ebay is taking active
measures to prohibit kids from ordering
i don't even know the names of the
titles look what happened on mulberry
street is that one of them
actively monitoring to to
prohibit banned cartoon books for
children mineconf by the way is still on
ebay mineconf
hitler's book still you can still buy
mineconf you can sell mineconf why is
that some people are pointing out the
hypocrisy
it's not hypocrisy it's a strategy
mineconf
is not a threat to the left
dr seuss is much more of a threat to the
left than mein kampf because dr
seuss does not toe the politically
correct
line it shows you that we used to have
sort of we were a little looser about
some things we tell
jokes about one another we were not so
agitated we didn't all couch out to this
grievance politics
mein kampf actually helps the left
because what the left wants to do
is say that all of their enemies are
nazis and in order
for that calumny to have any weight
they need to keep nazis in our mind all
the time i wouldn't be surprised if the
left starts mailing out copies of mind
conf to everybody
so that they can still have this boogie
man and tell us that half of our
countrymen
are nazis far more important that they
banned dr seuss than they ban
hitler this
seems to me in the wake of the mirage
coup d'etat yesterday when the
mainstream media told us the right wing
is going to have an insurrection a coup
d'etat
seems to me we're having a bit of a
silent insurrection and we have
for months and months and months and
it's not being perpetrated by the right
it's being perpetrated by the left
which is slowly but steadily gradually
upending our entire political order
they've been doing this in a very subtle
way
for about a hundred years through
political correctness which is
coincidentally
the subject of my book which will no
doubt be banned by
big tech soon enough the book doesn't
come out until june 22 you can pre-order
now which might be your best chance to
get it
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it details
step by step how the left has has
advanced this campaign but it also
points out that the campaign is not what
we thought it was
the way the right has fought against
political correctness is completely
failed we've pretended it's a battle
between free speech and censorship it's
not
it's a battle between two competing
standards and our
strategies that we've used to fight it
are completely wrong they're actually
counterproductive
and we need to completely change course
otherwise
you're going to have this subtle gradual
insurrection whereby our election rules
completely changed
whereby our method of
persuading our fellow citizens in our
republic completely
compromised in a republic our ability to
persuade one another that is politics
if they in big technology or in the
left-wing establishment broadly
if they can curtail that they utterly
control the politics if they can censor
former presidents
they can completely upend our culture if
dr seuss i mean we've been making fun of
the dr seuss thing for a while dr seuss
is actually crucial to the fight
if they can cancel
a beloved children's author and if they
can totally control
the way that children's minds are formed
they will control our politics
meanwhile the argument for banning soos
is
anti-racism so-called anti-racism
anti-racist ideology quote unquote is
also being used
to transform the country at our southern
border right now
there is a surge in our southern border
the number of young
migrants who are being referred to
hhs for release into the u.s has surged
600 percent since president trump
left office 600 percent
a flood of new people entering the
country undermines our sovereignty and
also gives democrats likely voters i'm
just
looking at public opinion surveys in
2020 30
000 unaccompanied minors arrived at the
southern
border administration officials estimate
that this year
they will they will see 117 000
unaccompanied minors we know why the
left is doing this
why the left is encouraging this because
one it tugs on the heart strings it
makes their opponents look awful if we
don't want to let in
all sorts of unaccompanied minors who by
the way
are facing horrible conditions as they
come into this country they're often
being brought over
through coyotes there was a statistic
that came out years ago from huffington
post
and fusion i believe which said that
something like 60
or more of young women and girls who
cross the border illegally or raped or
sexually assaulted on the journey
it's really a terrible journey for young
people the left is incentivizing that
because they think we're not going to
find out about that sort of thing and
because they know
that they're very likely to be able to
count on their votes later on but
doesn't this raise a problem
the left is telling us that
the fact that in florida
you can go to a restaurant the fact that
in florida you can leave your home
is tantamount to mass murder it's
irresponsible republicans killing all of
us because people can move freely within
their own towns
but at the same time they're telling us
that we need to welcome hundreds of
thousands of migrants
who have not really been screened who
have not
i assume they're not wearing masks who
are pouring across the border
isn't this a bit of a contradiction if
we're allowed to have hundreds of
thousands of people cross into our
country illegally from who knows
where shouldn't i be able to go down the
street and go to the restaurant
joy reid of msnbc says this question
absolutely
wrong unjust and racist
after following desantis down the covet
denial path and recklessly opening up
his state
without any restrictions this week he's
deflecting criticism
by dishing out anti-immigrant xenophobia
the by the administration was releasing
illegal immigrant
illegal immigrants into our communities
who had coveted
the bite administration was spreading
covet in
south texas yesterday because of their
lack of constraint
of testing and quarantining people who'd
come across the border illegally
the bite administration uh was exposing
texans to covet
that is neanderthal type approach to
dealing with the kova situation
so for that absurdly racist claim
governor abbott
is the absolute worst for the second
time this week
that absurdly racist totally true claim
makes governor abbott the worst governor
abbott said
that kovit is being released into texas
because of the method in which the
federal government is taking in
immigrants illegal immigrants
that's obviously true joy reid does not
dispute that it's
common sense and it follows all of the
logic
of the pandemic so she's not saying it's
not true she's just saying it's also
racist can you
this is a subtle shift but it is an
important one
when i think of what is racism i think
racism is
unjust it's
wicked wrong and therefore
it can't be true it can't be based on
true things
if i say something that is true
and the truth offends somebody that's
not my problem
that doesn't make me a racist
what joy rita is saying is and there was
actually a comedy video years ago that
was going around youtube
that said they said just because
something's true doesn't mean it's not
racist
and joyride is now saying that earnestly
she's saying don't you dare say true
things
because if you do i'll call you a bigot
and we will
suppress your speech and we will censor
you that's the message of the broader
left-wing establishment we're seeing
this
day by day all of us in our individual
lives actually there's a woman who went
viral on tick-tock yesterday
who is claiming that she was fired from
her job
for doing her job because a woman
of a racial minority was able to claim
without any evidence
that she was offended implying the woman
did something wrong
and the young woman lost your job so i
normally don't do this on tick tock but
today i
am livid so i want your opinion to see
if this kind of thing is justified
so i work at a retail store and i've
worked there now for like a year and a
half well i'm moving these racks and i
didn't want to hit anyone so i kind of
look to each side to see
if anyone's on the other side to see if
i can move it well i look this way and i
end up seeing someone so i stop
and i don't move it well she instantly
looks at me and says can i help you with
something
and i'm like oh no i'm sorry i was just
going to move the rack and i want to
make sure i didn't hit anyone
well then she says i want to put a
corporate complaint against you for
racial profiling because apparently
i looked at her the wrong way and was
assuming she didn't have money
i would never just assume someone
doesn't have money by what they look
like that is
stupid well i had to give a whole
statement about the thing and
overall they called me up today and
fired me due to
me looking at someone and being racist
so do you think that's justified or do
you think that's wrongful termination
because i'm pissed
i don't know if this particular story
that this woman is telling is true i
have no reason to disbelieve it
but i think we have all seen
evidence that these sorts of things
happen just the woca cola be less white
campaign that linkedin has now taken off
of their platform
thankfully just that alone shows you
that this sort of thing
happens you can be accused of racism for
saying something that's true you can be
accused of racism
for looking at someone
i don't necessarily blame the
left-wingers who are using this
political strategy
because the left is frequently dishonest
they they if they are rejecting a sort
of transcendent moral order then they
really have no problem with
being dishonest and lying about these
things and it's very effective
it's a grift it's a total
grift we're seeing actually some
fissions
among some of the most prominent race
hustlers in the country
because race hustling is big business
blm has taken in lots and lots
of donations since the george floyd
killing
or the george floyd death i guess we'll
find out in the trial whether he died
of drugs or health problems or whether
he died because he was
he was killed by somebody
but this is big business i read that
there are some numbers it's hard to get
exact
exact numbers here but i have read that
blm has taken in something like
90 million dollars might be
significantly more than that
and some other race hustlers want in on
the action
the family of michael brown you remember
michael brown michael brown
was a young man in ferguson missouri
who robbed a store then was walking down
the street
and then charged a police officer
grabbed his gun and sadly was killed
in this incident officer doesn't appear
to have done
anything wrong but it is a sad incident
a guy died
just generally speaking that's a sad
thing so
the michael brown incident helped to to
start the black lives matter movement
because
the reality of what happened to michael
brown was completely rewritten
we were told he was a gentle giant we
were told he had his hands up
and he said hands up don't shoot didn't
happen was completely contradicted by
the witnesses and the grand jury
but that myth launched blm now blm's
making a lot of money and now michael
brown's family
and some of the local community
organizers
also known as race agitators in ferguson
are demanding a cut of the action
mike brown senior and tony russell a
local organizer
have demanded that the black lives
matter organization provide
20 million dollars to continue their
work
in ferguson missouri 20 million dollars
to continue the very important work of
michael brown senior and tony russell
what work is that
i don't know can't quite describe it but
anyway pay up
there is a certain satisfaction in
watching these extortion artists
extort one another these these shakedown
artists
try to run the con on one another and
frankly i don't i don't blame
these guys mr mr brown or mr russell
i don't blame him blm organization or
grifter's just like
race hustlers all around the country so
why should why should one group of them
get all the money
doesn't make a lot of sense
this system
is everywhere it's in corporate
boardrooms as we saw
last week it's in retail shops it
certainly would appear to be
it's in universities it's down in
kindergarten education kindergarteners
are now being taught
anti-racism which is just a code word
for radical leftist
ideology this is all
over our country where is the real
insurrection where is the real coup is
the insurrection what happened yesterday
on march 4th which
proved a mirage or is the insurrection
the ideological transformation that's
gone on for decades now backed up by
actual
violence in the streets for six to eight
months during 2020 when leftist radicals
burn down
our country this may be i'm sorry to say
the new normal
and the new normal these these policies
forget racial grievance for a second
even the
so-called public health policies that
have totally upended
our american way of life that have
canceled holidays that have prevented us
from seeing one another that have taken
away so many of our liberties
they might be here to say dr paul offit
who's the director of the vaccine
education center in philly
he's a member of the fda's vaccine
advisory committee
he was interviewed on cnn and he says
you know look once we get coveted under
control
someday that'll happen uh we should
probably just keep wearing the masks
anyway
we figure out what flu strains have been
circulating in places like australia
or south america which sort of predicts
what what strains are likely to come
into our country
there's been so little flu in those two
areas i think it's going to be hard for
us
to try and figure out what flu strains
to pick but you're right it's if we mask
in social distance every winter we will
see a dramatic reduction in flu which
usually causes
hundreds of thousands of
hospitalizations and tens of thousands
of deaths i wonder whether that would be
will be the lesson
from this it's certainly the lesson that
you people want to voice donnis
but it's not the lesson that i'm going
to take you know i was i knew this was
going to happen i was speaking to
a generally more conservative public
health expert there aren't too many
conservatives in that particular field
it's just a leftist field it it involves
a left-wing way of thinking about the
world and about politics
but i was talking to a guy who's more
center more right-wing
and he said you know michael maybe this
isn't the worst thing
we were kind of crazy before you'd go
out when you had the sniffles
that's kind of crazy we shouldn't be
doing that right i think we should i
think it is
disordered to wear masks in public like
bacteria-ridden banditos i think that it
is
inhuman to cover up our mouths our
speech
the the essential quality that makes us
human and that defines our
system of government at least the one
we've had for a couple hundred years now
it's wrong it's just intrinsically wrong
i would rather
see people smiling faces hug my
relatives and celebrate christmas
then maybe avoid getting the sniffles
i never get the flu shot and i don't
intend to i don't tend to get this
vaccine either
if i were much much older i'd consider
getting the flu shot and i'd consider
getting the
coronavirus shot but i'm not not saying
i'm
invincible i guess there's a terrible
world in which a bad flu takes me
god forbid or a covet or something but
i'm willing to take the risk we all take
risks in society
i would rather have a human well-ordered
society where i can see everybody's
smiling face than than not have a
light cough this is the common sense
this is actually the one hope that i
think we all have here
the father of what you might call
neo-marxism
cultural marxism is a term that's used a
very important figure in western marxism
is antonio gramsci
i write about him at great length in my
book
gramsci is the head of the italian
former head of the italian communist
party he was imprisoned by mussolini
uh one of the worst things mussolini
ever did was imprison this guy because
it gave him a chance to write
if he was going to imprison him he
should have taken away his pen and paper
he wrote the prison notebooks he wrote
he wrote about
that this uh one issue that marxists
have which is
they don't have a grasp on the common
sense the conservatives have the common
sense they have cultural hegemony and
they just
a lot of people when you hear these
cockamamie left-wing theories you just
say that doesn't sound right to me this
is why the left
has to transform our way of thinking he
has to get into the schools very early
has to force on us a new normal so that
they can transform the common sense and
we don't question their
crazy ideas i think conservatives still
have the common sense i think in many
ways this is why trump an
anti-ideological candidate a common
sense candidate
did so well in 2016. there was a woman
who summed this up to me she
she pulled up she's just gone viral in a
video on social media
she pulls up to a fast food counter
they're gonna hand her her food
some fast food places tell you to wear
masks i obviously never do that but i
guess sometimes they're sticklers
and the the person refuses to hand the
woman her food
he'll hand her a mask but not her food
she's very confused
no i don't i can give you one uh you can
give me one
i can give you one i need you to wear
math so you can hand me a mask
i can hand you one yeah but you can't
hand me the drink without a mask
you've got to wear a mask how does that
make any sense
that's what that's what i i just need
you to wear a mouth when you do your
mind well if you can hand me a mask why
can't you just hand me the drink
i can hand you to math
uh listen sir i have two brain cells to
rub together and an
uh even a modicum of independent thought
so i'm just pointing out to you that
what you're saying doesn't make any
sense
uh uh uh wear the mask beep boop
beep beep boop wear the mask wear the
mask
this is the battle right now when we're
talking about the insurrections the
coups
yeah there is there is a cultural coup
that's going on in our country right now
and we're trying to stave that off and
the two battle lines are exactly what
you've heard there
the people who go along
to get along the fast food guy and the
woman
who i don't know her politics but i know
that she has at least a little bit of
common sense left
if we cannot hold the common sense if we
cannot stave off
and shatter the new normal then that
that will be the final blow
if we can hold on to the common sense
we have a chance we are
going to be hearing about all sorts of
common sense questions from ben
today we're also going to be hearing
about neanderthals we're also going to
be
hearing about joe biden head on over
listen to his show and you know there's
another show you can listen to from ben
that would be debunked lots of crazy
left-wing ideas
that go unchallenged in our society well
ben
with his lightning-fast reflexes of
facts and logic is going to go in and
debunk a bunch of
crazy left-wing claims in 15 minutes or
less
he's talking about minimum wage on this
most recent episode head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe this is exclusively a show for
daily wire members
so if you go head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe use code
debunked
you'll get 25 off your new membership
stay tuned for this friday's
episode where ben will break down the
unions hopefully he'll break the unions
as well but he'll definitely break down
the unions we'll be back with a lot more
it is my favorite time of the week the
mailbag first question from michael
dear michael when will you be launching
the daily wire
dating app i'm sick of the hot singles
in my area not sharing my conservative
and traditional values
in all seriousness i was that not
serious that's fair enough it seems like
a serious statement
he goes on in all seriousness i live in
the most liberal city in wisconsin and i
can't seem to meet any respectable women
it's the new spelling this shares my
values i have not left
because i have a great job and i'm close
to home and family do you have any
advice for seeking out the ladies worth
their salt or some inspiration
to up and move to a more conservative
state p.s nice name thank you michael
i reciprocate the compliment
it's tricky for me to give advice here
because i
met my wife when we were like 10 years
old or something
not saying we got married right away you
know dated other people in the meantime
but
but i just have a sort of different
dating experience
than many people do and i i
was never on the dating apps for
instance i
did not have to date during this
particularly crazy political time
so in many ways i dodged a bullet sorry
to gloat but that's the way it goes
i left a liberal state and moved to a
conservative state and i did it for
professional reasons first of all and
also personal reasons because it's
easier to raise a kid
in a more normal conservative state and
i love it and i miss some of my friends
in california but
basically i wish i had moved here even
sooner to tennessee i absolutely
love it a lot of people are doing this
in the country right now they are
moving to places to follow their
philosophical lights because as the
country becomes more politically
polarized you're going to you're not
going to want to live in some crazy
place
where everyone disagrees with you about
everything and just views the world
fundamentally differently
i'm not saying we can't have nice
conversations with people who are on the
left
i'm just saying if we're talking about
radically different views of the world
it's going to be harder to get along
there
where to meet a good woman if you're
having trouble
on the dating apps and i know people
have gotten married off the apps if
you're
not able to go to bars because of stupid
kovid
i would recommend making friends through
other affinity groups
namely your church that would be the
easiest one
but even through more
interest-based groups rather than you
know religion which is the fundament
more more interests the examples of this
are
and kind of gets to my theory of how the
country is changing and
transforming and now going back to a
different version of what it used to be
before we had standardization and mass
media sort of before world war ii
we had much more local cultures so
tennessee would be very different from
i don't know uh california very very
different
unrecognizable maybe now though they are
still quite different
they're much more similar than they used
to be and if you go to cities and all
these different places the cities are
almost exactly the same i've traveled
all over this country and
it's more similar than it is different
maybe that will change with polarization
again i'm not quite sure
but the local question kind of went away
now that the mainstream media and the
standardization is breaking
i think we are we're going away from a
common culture again we're not all
watching the same tv shows we're not all
watching the same movies we're not all
watching the same sports
we're not all watching the same newsmen
so that's breaking away in a way that's
good it's
in a sense kind of a return to localism
but it's not localism rooted in
geography it's rooted in
ideological affinity groups in many ways
so it's not that once the mainstream
media and the common culture cracks
we're all just going back to our local
vfw hall
it's that we're all going online and
talking to people who have the same
interests that we do
on the other side of the country or
maybe even on the other side of the
world
i i'm not willing to speculate now on
what that means for our politics but
what it means for you is
maybe you'll meet a lovely lady through
the daily wire
audience community i actually saw on
twitter there was a singles chat going
on in the daily wire community
i do think that you're going to have to
look more specifically into your
interest groups into your affinity
groups
than just the local bar i think the new
normal in many ways is shutting that
down
from matthew michael i was listening to
the ben shapiro show and would ask him
this but he doesn't respond to the
mailbag
real nice i'm number two i'm your
plan b really sweet of you for the
conservatives fighting the culture war
what does victory look like
there are some people who want the
conservative cultural wind to just be
returned to the 1950s
there are some people who want a
conservative cultural win to be a return
to the
1350s you know in medieval europe or
something
i'm kind of more in favor of that than
of the former ultimately what it is a
conservative cultural win
is a society ordered toward the good
the true and the beautiful so rob amari
wrote
something to this effect a few years ago
in first things
a conservative cultural win is a society
that recognizes
that there is such a thing as the good
and that some things are better than
others
the left currently espouses this and the
right tries to pretend that we can't
the right has basically embraced a
radical skepticism that says well
i can't tell you that you should do this
or you shouldn't do this you just do
whatever you want i'll do whatever i
want and and we'll all be totally fine
that that doesn't make any sense all
societies have to acknowledge that some
things are better than other things
so if we can get past that kind of
ridiculous hump which i try to do in my
new book speechless
then you have to say well what is the
good
through our faculty is the reason we can
do that
an example of how far we've fallen just
look at architecture
from 100 years ago well from 50 years
ago
100 years ago 150 years ago compared to
today
the architecture used to look more
beautiful
it was ordered more toward beauty then
there was a trend
in recent years to go away from beauty
to to focus on functionality or utility
and then there's been a trend in even
more recent years to actively
embrace ugly things that's why we live
in an ugly society
roger scrutin the recently departed
conservative philosopher
said that if you want people to love
their country you need to give them a
beautiful country
something as simple as that give them a
beautiful place to live and they'll like
where they live
we need to take seriously those kind of
questions
we need to take moral questions much
more seriously and we need to take
factual questions what is what is true
much more seriously than we do now
because we don't maybe we don't want to
offend people or we don't want to incur
the wrath of the pc mob we have to
hit all three of those things that's a
very different kind of
political vision than just uh cut my
taxes and leave me alone
but cut my taxes and leave me alone has
not worked out very well
for us it hasn't given us
it hasn't led to permanent tax cuts and
it hasn't even left us alone so it just
it just doesn't work we need to
we need to dig in much more seriously
from stephanie the other day
one of my last remaining lefty friends
told me that she wants the lockdowns and
mandatory masking to go on forever
she has a second grader in school with
my daughter and says that she is happy
not to have gotten so much as a runny
nose kind of like that doctor on cnn
i was honestly baffled by this
particular world view
and new level of cowardice that she'd be
willing to give up her life to maybe
live longer or live life without any
runny noses
since she and i are both catholic i
wondered if you might have a theological
answer to this that i haven't thought of
when i tried to respond by saying that
there was more to life than just
surviving she scoffed at me
and said i don't value my health enough
i really want to continue this
friendship but i thought you might have
some answers for me thanks yes
absolutely
chesterton famously described heresy
not as the promotion of vice over virtue
but
of the promotion of some virtue to the
exclusion of all the other virtues so
having your health is a good thing
but it is not the
end of life it is not the purpose of
life to maintain our good health all the
time
if we think that it is we are making an
idol out of that and we fall
into heretical ways of thinking
i'll give you a very specific example
with the covid lockdowns
we are not permitted and for for a long
period of of the past year and a half
or i guess yeah we're coming up on the
now the one-year anniversary 365 days to
slow the spread
for the better part of the last year we
have not been permitted
to receive the sacraments we've not been
permitted to go to church
and if you're catholic you know we have
an incarnational faith you need to
receive the sacraments
it is much more important to receive the
sacraments
than to avoid the sniffles it is much
more important
we are incarnational beings we are not
just disembodied souls we are souls with
bodies
joined together hylomorphic beings is
the technical term
and we need to do things we need to see
one another
it is also simply disordered
to walk around like banditos all the
time
and not see your relatives and not hug
your loved ones and not
go to their funerals and not bring
people together for the births of
children for important events
to keep people away from their education
that is
disordered to not celebrate christmas
for one that is disordered
and i suspect your friend is taking a
good thing which is health
and making an idol out of it which is
why her view of the world is so
screwy from brady hi michael i enjoyed
the changing attire discussion that you
all had on the daily wire backstage last
week
we were all talking about whether or not
we'd ever changed a tire and i said that
i
i actually had changed a tire it's the
manliest thing i've ever done i've only
done it like once or twice
uh but yeah some of the other guys had
not done it
so brady writes my wife and mother of my
four children can confirm that while we
were dating
the night i had to change a tire in a
full suit after a banquet
is still probably the most manly thing
i've ever done what are your thoughts
slash plans for your children in looking
for a spouse
my wife and i have discussed the idea of
courtship but are unsure of how lenient
strict to be in our policies thanks and
keep up the amazing work
this ties in actually with that that
earlier answer we were giving which is
i grew up in a very liberal environment
my mother was fairly conservative you
know
my family was kind of moderately
conservative
kind of moderately liberal they were
sort of in the middle but in a very
liberal place very liberal school very
liberal friends very liberal everybody
and so we were not encouraged to undergo
any kind of
new contrived formal courtship
we were encouraged to do the opposite of
that
when we were young and irresponsible we
were encouraged to be young and
irresponsible
and we made all sorts of mistakes and
dated all sorts of people and did all
sorts of things we shouldn't have done
and then somehow i ended up
married to my high school sweetheart in
this very
sort of traditional setup with a very
traditional view of the world after 10
years of being an atheist and a brief
stint of considering being a lib
i came back and now i'm to the right of
attila the hunt
had i been raised in a much more formal
kind of
uh conservative setting i don't know how
that would have worked out i mean i'm
sorry that i lost 10 years being an
atheist derelict
but i'm all's well that ends well you
know as st
john vianney said not all the saints
started well but they all ended well so
i
the thing i would tell you which is i
don't think it's a cop out i think it's
actually conservative insight
is you you you value all the values and
include
prudence prudence is a virtue and it's a
particularly conservative virtue
i think you've got to gear it toward
your individual
children if one of your kids
just is a wild child you're going to
probably need to put some more
constraints on that kid
if one of your kids is basically
buttoned up and a good kid
then maybe you loosen up a little bit
and it's going to depend on who your
kids are attracted to
if they're attracted to you know johnny
on the harley you know
taking your daughter or behind the gym
after school or something then you know
maybe you're going to have to have a
tougher hand in this sort of thing
and if not then you're going to be able
to be a little bit more lenient but i
think
we shouldn't just have some ideological
ten bullet point this is exactly what
you should do
you're talking about your family you're
talking about real relationships you're
talking about very particular things
you should you should follow specificity
and prudence
final question from mp i'm 25 wrapping
up
my final semester of graduate school in
philosophy at franciscan university of
steubenville one of my absolute favorite
universities in the country
my plan prior to starting the current
semester was to enter the u.s navy and
take the legal route
after hearing about some of the new
policies the navy's putting in place
that are very left-wing
i'm not so sure anymore i want to serve
my country and join the military but i
don't want to be dishonorably discharged
because i can't go along with their new
policies
do you think a catholic can still serve
in the military despite these policies
thanks love the show and all you guys at
the daily wire
i do think that a catholic can still
serve in the navy i come from a navy
family myself
lots of relatives in the navy and
so i think they can it's very
frustrating what the navy and the
government bureaucracies in general the
military's not excluded from that
are doing in terms of political
correctness but i i don't think
you're in a position right now i don't
think the situation's gotten so bad
that you would not be able to uh live
your faith
and still serve in the navy it requires
sacrifice perhaps one of those
sacrifices is putting up with pc
policies
until we can get someone in there at the
political level to
reverse them until we can start to undo
this
silent coup that's been going on for a
long time i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
see you next week
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin